[Musique]
la 23e édition du challenge des
créateurs a été lancée dans les eaux de
grands coups de chez sandro k'bidi
gagnant du prix du jury l'année dernière
le jardin des bestioles expose des
sculptures d'animaux et d'insectes à 90%
en métal recyclé sur dix mille mètres
carrés de jardin
ça m'a permis de créer des projets que
j'avais en tête ici et aussi dire non
quand même de la trésorerie ça ça ça m'a
aidé pendant les deux ans parce que
quand nouveau l'entreprise les deux
premières années celles des années les
plus dures et ça ça m'a permis quand
même de tenir jusqu'à maintenant avec
aussi le co vite ça arrange pas les
choses
il faut pas hésiter moi personnellement
j'avais hésité aussi au début
aujourd'hui ben là la première rangée le
prix du jury il faut pas hésiter même si
on croit très clair son projet il faut y
aller soit y aller faut y aller l'appel
à candidatures pour cette année donc
lancé jusqu'au 16 octobre à minuit cette
catégorie récompense concept lauréat à
hauteur de 7000 euros et sept finalistes
à hauteur de 1500 euros du conseil
personnalisé de la formation et du
coaching seront également offerts par
les partenaires
pour plus d'informations rendez vous sur
le site du département en www.dhltd.com
en offset 4 point fr
[Musique]